[Music]
the star of the hit netflix show tiger
king is asking president trump
for a pardon cbs news has exclusively
obtained the final version of the
application
joe exotic will submit to the white
house earlier this year exotic whose
legal name by the way is joseph
maldonado big difference
was sentenced to 22 years in prison now
a jury convicted him for a
murder-for-hire plot and for
illegally selling and killing tigers
paula reed has seen his application
paula i remember when the president was
actually
asked about a pardon during a white
house briefing and it seemed
so far-fetched at the time now maybe not
so much so you've seen the application
what'd you learn
you never know what to expect here at
the white house gail the president at
that time he said he'd look into it
and i have read the handwritten letter
that joe exotic sent to president trump
from
prison he makes a direct appeal to
president trump's ego he tells the
president that he is his
hero and interestingly he invokes the
president's criticism
of federal investigators he tells the
president i have seen what they
do to you a reference of course to the
president's criticism of the russia
investigation
now in the actual pardon application his
lawyers argue that joe exotic was just
some quote
gay gun-toting redneck in oklahoma
before his recent fame they argue he
didn't get a fair trial
he didn't get a robust defense that's
why they're arguing for clemency
will this work well usually you have to
wait five years before you even apply
for a pardon
joe exotic is asking for that to be
waived and we've seen with president
trump he has a history of granting
clemency to celebrities
or those with celebrity advocates and
those who are politically aligned with
his views
and we expect that the physical copy of
this pardon application
will be hand delivered to the white
house as soon as tomorrow
tony very interesting paula thank you
very much